Buonasera a tutti grazie Sono veramente
molto onorata di essere qui al The Dix
Biella e oggi provo a raccontarmi il mio
Working the future partendo
da una domanda
una domanda che per me è stata dire una
tra le più complicate a cui trovare una
risposta e probabilmente non l'ho ancora
trovata la seconda è che lavoro fai a
cui tipicamente rispondo quanto tempo
hai perché nonostante per dieci anni
faccia da 10 anni faccio lo stesso
lavoro mia mamma non l'ha ancora capito
ma tornando a questa domanda Cosa vuoi
fare da grande perché è una domanda che
mi ha sempre molto destabilizzato non
tanto perché insomma già da bambina non
sapessi insomma che cosa mi piaceva fare
cosa Ma perché diciamo quelle etichette
no che che conoscevo le professioni
eccetera non mi non si presentavano non
sentivo di trovare qualche cosa che
insomma che che rispecchiava quello che
avrei voluto fare poi sono andata a
scuola come come tutti noi e Però devo
dire che anche qui non essendoci Pur
essendoci Insomma momenti dedicati
all'orientamento su cui forse si può si
può ancora lavorare Ecco non sono
riuscita a trovare effettivamente una
risposta che che mi soddisfacesse e su
questo faccio un piccolissimo inciso vi
voglio raccontare di uno speech che ho
sentito qualche tempo fa perché è molto
significativo in quanto non si può
parlare del mondo del lavoro senza
prendere in considerazione tutto il
mondo della Formazione che poi al lavoro
ci porta e ho sentito qualche settimana
fa ad un evento a Torino che si chiama
italian te qui con uno speech di un
tedesco founder di una startup che si
chiama Ghost student andatelo a vedere
se vi capita che raccontava nel
raccontare il suo modello di business di
Festival della scuola del futuro Qual è
stata l'evoluzione adesso io qui per
esigenze di tempo ve la faccio breve ma
insomma raccontava di come la scuola è
voluta no dall'antica Grecia che era
quasi un One To One dove c'era un un
maestro un discente poi c'erano
tipicamente due due strade il guerriero
il filosofo no che si potevano scegliere
però era molto focalizzato
sull'individuo poi grazie a Dio diciamo
anche la scuola è diventata per per
tanti per tutti direi ma si è molto
standardizzata quindi una scuola che
doveva dare un certo tipo di competenze
tutti uguali a tutte le persone e questo
sicuramente ha diciamo così fatto
perdere
il focus E l'interesse su quelle che
sono le attitudini di Ciascuna persona
si è parlato anche prima no di Soft
Skills competenze diverse da quelle
tecniche che si apprendono nella nostra
scuola e oggi è questo quello che
raccontava questo ragazzo la scuola ha
capito con la scuola a distanza che
tanti genitori seguita l'abbiamo capito
ancora di più deve prendere un'altra
strada perché per preparare gli
individui al mondo del futuro che verrà
è necessario lavorare su una scuola
molto più esperienziale che investe
sulle attitudini dei bambini sulle
capacità che dicevamo prima cognitive
eccetera e quindi questo è sicuramente
un auspicio è qualcosa che ci serve per
preparare i ragazzi al mondo al mondo
del futuro e quindi forse Serve un
cambio di paradigma e mentre Riflettevo
su queste cose così su questo video
grande
Dicci Cosa vogliamo fare Ora voglio
arrivare sulle nuvole
[Musica]
[Applauso]
Io voglio ballare essere un gigante
voglio fare come meglio
vedere il mondo Voglio colorare come un
treno
per poteri non vogliamo fermarci mai
cosa vuoi fare ora
[Musica]
Ecco mi piaceva farvelo vedere perché
sicuramente questa domanda ma in realtà
quello che ci dice Questo video è un
cambio di mindset completamente diverso
mi avrebbe aiutato forse a trovare la
strada e a capire che era molto
importante che cosa sentivo io dentro
perché è importante adesso e perché ho
fatto questo passaggio sul mondo della
scuola perché oggi ce lo diceva anche il
relatore di prima siamo immersi in un
cambiamento incredibile no e l'era della
trasformazione digitale di cui Tanti
hanno paura ma è qualcosa di inevitabile
è il momento del cambiamento è ancora
una volta però in questa locuzione la
parola importante non è tanto digitale
Sì perché la tecnologia sta cambiando
moltissimo sta abilitando
nuovi modi di fare le cose ma la parola
chiave l'uomo la sua centralità e
lavorare su di lui per capire come dovrà
essere pronto per per il mondo del
lavoro del futuro e ho avuto la
straordinaria fortuna davvero in questi
anni di incontrare il fondatore a cui
poi mi sono aggregata di Talent Garden
che è uno spazio che aveva capito un po'
prima no dell'accelerazione che c'è
stata soprattutto adesso che il mondo
del lavoro sarebbe cambiato
e che c'era Quindi la necessità di
mettere insieme tra l'altro questi nuovi
talenti queste nuove capacità che
venivano dal mondo della tecnologia del
digitale di metterli insieme perché era
fondamentale connetterli dalla loro
lavoro comune nascevano soluzioni a
problemi nuovi ed è stato veramente un
per me 10 anni di una cavalcata
appassionante ho visto
lavori che fino a poco tempo prima non
c'erano ho visto ragazzi che creavano
nuove aziende ho visto
grandissime aziende che venivano in
questi spazi a chiedere ai ragazzi agli
studenti di Digital marketing nuove
soluzioni per implementare i nuovi
modelli di business e le loro aziende
quindi è stato veramente affascinante e
mentre creavamo questi spazi Oggi ne
abbiamo
tantissimi in tutta Europa dove appunto
connettiamo abilitiamo questi Talenti
abbiamo capito che
era una grande necessità per il mondo
del lavoro del futuro e cioè preparare
delle nuove competenze prima su tutte ed
è quella su cui noi siamo esperti sono
le competenze digitali e guardate ai
programmi delle nostre scuole tanto per
parlare di quello che ho detto prima
ahimè non siamo ancora preparati Eppure
è tutto quello che è design io ex you ai
tutto quello che coding cioè sono parole
oggi a volte buzzurri Ma così
sconosciute che però sono fondamentali
per di nuovo per il mondo del lavoro di
domani e sono fondamentali soprattutto
perché un'altra delle parole che
sentiamo oggi sempre più è il famoso
Skills match cioè Voi leggete sui
giornali ricerche su ricerche abbiamo
più di 350 mila posizioni lavorative
aperte
poiché non ci sono persone che hanno
quelle competenze Allora capite che in
un Paese come l'Italia che ha un tasso
di disoccupazione giovanile così alto è
qualcosa che non possiamo permettersi e
quindi è fondamentale lavorare su questo
tipo di competenze che davvero ci
traghetteranno nel nel mondo del lavoro
del futuro e mi riaggancio a quello che
veniva detto prima
l'altra cosa fondamentale accanto alle
competenze digitali sono qua non lo dico
io lo dice McKenzie le cosiddette
foundations Oggi abbiamo bisogno non
soltanto di competenze tecniche ma
sempre di più di quello che sono
competenze di pensiero critico di
comunicazione e di flessibilità di
competenze interpersonali saper lavorare
in team di essere leader di ispirare
fiducia cioè sono davvero parole chiave
per quello che sarà il mondo del lavoro
del futuro
e poi aggiungiamoci ancora un pezzo
perché il mondo del lavoro sta vedendo
arrivare una nuova generazione sempre di
più no si parla dei millennials io ci
sto ancora per pochino ma mi ci sento
dentro e la generazione Z Ecco questo
tipo di popolazione che abiterà già
abita il mondo del lavoro vuole
interazione vuole condividere idee vuole
essere ascoltata allora pensate Quanto
stanno cambiando le aziende col momento
dove si racconta addirittura la
performance economica a tutta l'azienda
qualsiasi livello questo forse
impensabile fino a poco tempo fa pensate
a come si generano
le Challenge all'interno dell'azienda
Penso agli acato eccetera che servono a
fare innovazione e proposte di nuove
idee cioè e veramente un modo di
lavorare completamente diverso dal mio
punto di vista veramente appassionante
un ultimo pezzo ancora un altro
scherzo questa generazione ha bisogno di
una motivazione lo sentiamo da tanto
tempo ma pochi ci sono riusciti i
giovani e il mondo hanno necessità di
davvero lavorare in aziende che hanno
una Mission Chiara di
aziende che sanno che cosa vuol dire
l'impatto vogliono lasciare un'eredità
positiva e pensate però cosa tutto
questo poi vuol dire nel Day by day nel
lavoro quotidiano No che però è
veramente affascinante aggiungo un'altra
piccola cosa che di cui Insomma si è
molto parlato soprattutto nel recente
nel recente passato Smart Working remote
Working c'è una grandissima confusione
ma io ricordo in mezzo al covid mi è
arrivato la larva business review che
aveva questo titolo gigantesco e con
questa foto che diciamo work from mini
Wear oggi
nuove tecnologie consentono davvero di
poter lavorare chiaro non per tutti
questo va detto però da posti diversi
che però è di nuovo uno stravolgimento
di paradigma veramente importante
affascinante ma che di nuovo come tutte
le cose vanno gestite E allora questo
lavoro ripeto che non è non deve essere
solo remoto perché diceva prima
il mondo del lavoro del futuro richiede
all'uomo di portare il suo vero valore
aggiunto Cioè la sua presenza la sua
capacità creativa la sua capacità
cognitiva la sua capacità di leadership
di saper risolvere problemi nuovi ecco
tutto questo va fatto con grande
responsabilità Ecco spesso e questa è
una delle poche pochissime parole che
non non si mette vicino al tema Smart
Working ma vi assicuro
o quantomeno per me è una speranza ma
quello che ho visto negli ambienti dove
lavoro nei luoghi dove ho la fortuna di
sedere anche con i giovani imprenditori
l'unione di queste due cose questa
capacità di traghettarsi al mondo nuovo
porta davvero felicità Ecco perché ho
voluto dire
Smart Working più responsabilità uguale
davvero felicità e chiudo dicendomi una
cosa che
non stiamo effettivamente parlando di
Walking de future non stiamo ragionando
di qualche cosa che verrà perché tutto
quello che vi ho detto è assolutamente
presente oggi lo viviamo quotidianamente
se non lo facciamo è assolutamente tempo
di cambiare Allora il mio augurio o
anche avendovi raccontato un'esperienza
vera e di abbracciare il cambiamento
perché il mondo del lavoro del futuro ci
può dare davvero tantissime grandi
opportunità Grazie
[Applauso]